انضموا الينا من دنياك سلام خضر ومن خرسون
مراسل جزيره تامر صمادي وابدا معك تامر
اذا القصف متواصل ماذا في الجديد
نعم فداء القصف متواصل هنا في قلب المدينه
خيرسون تحديدا قرب الميناء النهري وعند
الميناء النهري الذي يتعرض لقصف روسي
متواصل منذ ساعات الصباح في الحقيقه اعمده
الدخان في كل مكان في كل مكان اينما تحركت
فداء في خير سون في الشوارع ستجدي اعمده
الدخان تتصاعد في كل مكان هذا واحد من
الاماكن الذي تعرض
للقصف مره اخرى هذا الصباح وهمم وهو قريب
جدا من البناء النهري في خيرسون ويقع في
محيطه وفي الحقيقه القصه لا يهدا متواصل
مستعر يشتد وتحديدا على المواقع العسكريه
المواقع الامنيه ونحن نتجول منذ ساعات
الصباح في قلب المدينه رصدنا العديد من
المقر الحكوميه الامنيه العسكريه التي
اخليت تماما من العاملين فيها نتيجه
تعرضها
الاستهداف المستمر للضرب المستمر في
المقابل تتحدث القوات الاوكرانيه عن قصف
مكتف تقوم به قواتها المرابطه على طول ضفه
نهر دنيبر من الجانب الاوكراني باتجاه
مواقع تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه كما
تشاهدون هذه هي حال الشوارع في قلب
المدينه حركه شبه معدومه ونزوح متواصل
وخدمات مقطوعه في عموم المدينه نتحدث عن
انقطاع في التيار الكهربائي وفي الماء وفي
الخدمات الرئيسيه في المدينه منذ ايام
بشكل متواصل حيث تقول القوات الاوكرانيه
بان ال- ال- القصف واستهداف البنيه
التحتيه لا يتوقف في مدينه خيرسون هذا ما
يتعلق بغير سون وقبل قليل ايضا اعلنا عن
استهداف احدى المناطق السكنيه في قلب
المدينه
السلطات عن اصابات في صفوف المدنيين لكن
التطورات ايضا متسارعه في زبرجه في زبرجه
قل السلطات الاوكرانيه بان قواتها تكثف من
قصف المواقع التي تتمركز فيها القوات
الروسيه تحديدا في توك ماك في ميلتوبيل
القريبه من المحطه النوويه همم في زبروجيا
وتتحدث عن اصابات في صفوف القوات الروسيه
وعن خسائر في العتاد والارواح وتقول ايضا
القوات الاوكرانيه تحديدا قياده عمليات
الجنوب بان القوات الروسيه تعزز من
تواجدها ومن تحصيناتها فيما يتعلق بخط
الدفاع الاول والثاني والثالث على طول ضفه
نهر النيبر من روسيا ايضا القصف متواصل في
منطقه همم او في مقاطعه دينبرو وسط جنوبيه
البلاد من قبل الجانب الروسي وفقا للقوات
الاوكرانيه تحديدا في منطقه همم في منطقه
ميكوبل وهذه المنطقه ايضا القريبه من محطه
الطاقه النوويه في جباره هذا ما يتعلق
بالتطورات في الجنوب وتحديدا في نيكولايب
التي تتعرض سواحلها
المناطق الساحليه فيها للقصف وفقا للقوات
الاوكرانيه وفي شرق البلاد المواجهات
مستعره صباح هذا اليوم بثت القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه تسجيلا مصورا لما قالت انه قصف
مكثف لمدينه باخموت وبثت لقطات من الجو في
هذا السياق وكاله بان القوات الاوكرانيه
ما زالت تسيطر على المدينه لكن محيط
المدينه بخموت وتحديدا القرى والبلدات في
جوارها تتعرض لنصف متواصل
والقوات الاوكرانيه تصد هجوما وتقدما
للقوات الروسيه هناك نعم